meeting new people can be intimidating
instead of worrying about how to make
yourself feel comfortable shift your
attitude to focus on making the people
around you feel comfortable if you're on
your own as a party join groups of three
or more they're typically more open to a
new person good job when it's just two
people
an unexpected third can feel like a
crowd don't wait for people to approach
you approach them smile warmly stand up
straight and make eye contact good
things come to those who initiate here
have a beer remember these words how
about you invite them to tell you about
themselves I have to go in the direction
they're most excited to go in well this
is awkward
one easy remedy for an awkward silence
is food recipes diets restaurants
everyone has something to say about food
stand and smile on phone interviews this
improves the quality of your voice and
will make you sound more confident hello
wait three seconds before answering
questions it helps you process the
question and you won't seem rushed or
nervous when standing in a circle of
people open it up to allow a new person
in you'll make a great impression on
that person and on the other people in
the circle my mom plays ice hockey when
exiting a conversation interrupt
yourself not them make it clear that you
enjoyed the conversation and that you
have a reason for leaving right I have
to go to work but it was great to meet
you great meeting you
what a gentleman yeah if I had a
daughter I would let her date in my
business like what are we gonna talk
about in this sandwiches comes flying at
the lower yeah